[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas cuando pensamos
en un lugar como singapur lo normal es
que lo primero que se nos venga a la
cabeza no se sean sus imponentes
rascacielos su enorme aeropuerto las
galerías comerciales o quizás su
elegante bahía coronada por elmer lyon y
el espectacular casino de marina bay
puede incluso que se nos vengan imágenes
de mucha muchísima gente junta al fin y
al cabo singapur es uno de los lugares
más densamente poblados de todo el
planeta y de hecho tan sólo el 30 por
ciento de su territorio está aún sin
construir y de ese porcentaje pues la
inmensa mayor parte del espacio son
montañas parques y otros espacios
protegidos así que como os podéis
imaginar singapur no es precisamente que
digamos una potencia agrícola a singapur
la podemos relacionar con la industria
financiera el comercio el turismo o su
puerto incluso tal vez con empresas de
alta tecnología pero desde luego no con
la agricultura no y es que de hecho
menos del 1 por ciento de todo su
territorio está ocupado por
explotaciones agrícolas
no es extraño que con el vertiginoso
crecimiento demográfico que singapur ha
registrado durante las últimas décadas
la mayor parte de su territorio se haya
utilizado para construir viviendas
oficinas y espacios comerciales esto ha
supuesto que virtualmente haya
desaparecido el sector primario del país
especialmente la agricultura y la
ganadería de esta forma mientras que en
el año 1960 sin aporte ni alrededor de
15 mil hectáreas de tierras de cultivo y
la actividad agraria suponía el 3% del
pib hoy son menos de 600 hectáreas y su
peso sobre el pib no alcanza el 0,02 por
ciento
[Música]
en otras palabras desde el año 1960
singapur ha perdido el 96% de la
superficie dedicada a la producción de
alimentos lo que por otra parte pues es
completamente normal a medida que se fue
haciendo más y más rico singapur
sustituyó los bueyes y los tractores por
lujoso rascacielos de oficinas
sucursales bancarias y bóvedas de oro y
singapur se ha convertido también en uno
de los principales centros mundiales de
almacenamiento de metales preciosos que
se guardan dentro de bóvedas en centros
de alta altísima seguridad pero no
penséis que sólo fue una cuestión
estrictamente económica sino incluso
también política por ejemplo en 1984 el
gobierno prohibió la apertura de nuevas
granjas de cerdos por los malos olores y
los problemas ambientales que planteaban
desde entonces el número se redujo de
unas 200 granjas a tan sólo 22 en 1990 y
hoy ya no queda absolutamente ninguna y
amigos como os podéis imaginar esta es
una dinámica que tiene consecuencias
para que os hagáis una idea a día de hoy
singapur apenas produce localmente en
torno al 8 por ciento de las necesidades
alimentarias básicas de su población
uno de los porcentajes más pequeños de
todo el mundo así que no les queda otra
que importar prácticamente todo lo que
necesitan para comer qué es lo que
ocurre en la mayoría de las ciudades y
que sí mismo pues no tienen nada de malo
lo que pasa es que singapur no solo es
una ciudad sino que también es un país
así que el suministro alimentario
depende de acuerdos internacionales del
comercio libre o de cómo fluctúan las
divisas a pesar de lo cual hay que decir
que ocupa la primera plaza en el índice
mundial de seguridad alimentaria fijaos
sin embargo un momento porque ahora tras
los estragos causados por la crisis del
sars coronavirus 2 en el comercio
mundial las cosas en singapur podrían
estar cambiando
de hecho de repente el gobierno de esta
ciudad país ha girado 180 grados y ha
puesto sobre la mesa su intención de
incrementar drásticamente la producción
agropecuaria con un modelo muy pero que
muy particular pero por qué porque ahora
el gobierno de uno de los lugares más
prósperos de todo el planeta quiere
hacer rebrotar nunca mejor dicho la
actividad agrícola tiene sentido hacerlo
es acaso realmente posible en una ciudad
como está dominada por rascacielos sedes
financieras internacionales
interminables del días comerciales y
edificios por todas partes queridos
amigos amigas que dice acompañarnos a
conocer mejor esta asombrosa apuesta del
gobierno de singapur pues empecemos
[Música]
el retorno de la agricultura
en singapur se han marcado un objetivo
el del plan 30 por 30 express esto es
conseguir producir el 30 por ciento de
los alimentos que consumen para el año
2030 y ojo porque cuando el gobierno de
singapur se propone algo raro es que no
lo consiga de momento el gobierno
invertido ya en esta apuesta a través de
diversas vías al menos 200 millones de
dólares entre ellos casi 40 millones
invertidos directamente por la agencia
de alimentos de singapur pero la
pregunta la gran pregunta es cómo
demonios se puede desarrollar la
agricultura en un lugar como éste pues
veréis el gobierno singapurense cree que
es algo que se puede lograr apostando
activamente por un nuevo tipo de
agricultura la conocida como agricultura
hi tec tecno agricultura o agricultura
de alta tecnología da igual el nombre el
caso es que esta forma de cultivar no
tiene prácticamente nada que ver con la
forma tradicional que todos conocemos
[Música]
una agricultura de alta tecnología es
una nueva forma de explotación intensiva
o incluso podríamos decir ultra
intensiva que supone aprovechar al
máximo el espacio disponible y ser super
eficiente para multiplicar el
rendimiento de la explotación si
pensamos en una plantación de lechugas
tradicional por ejemplo se requiere un
tiempo de crecimiento y unas condiciones
climáticas determinadas que no tienen
por qué darse en todas partes pues bien
todas estas limitaciones prácticamente
desaparecen en las tecnocracias lugares
que se parecen más son laboratorio que a
las instalaciones tradicionales que
todos conocemos en estas técnicas los
vegetales se cultivan en una especie de
invernaderos modernos dispuestos en
paredes verticales en filas unas encima
de las otras reciben luz y calor
artificial las condiciones de humedad y
temperatura se optimizan para cada
cultivo y se riega con agua enriquecida
en nutrientes e incluso en algunos casos
la recolección está automatizada con el
uso de robots
[Música]
vale suena casi a película de ciencia
ficción o ese tipo de proyectos
descabellados que se plantearon hace un
tiempo para cultivar vegetales en la
mismísima luna sin embargo queridos
amigos podéis creerme si os digo que de
ficción no tienen absolutamente nada
[Música]
en singapur y en otros países del mundo
este tipo de explotaciones está en pleno
auge y lo cierto es que se han
convertido en una actividad muy
prometedora esta ciudad-estado de la que
estamos hablando por ejemplo tiene ya 31
granjas operativas de este tipo cuando
en 2016 tenían tan solo 12 en los
últimos años de hecho tanto el número de
explotaciones agropecuarias como la
producción de alimentos están
experimentando un crecimiento constante
tanto la producción de vegetales como
también las de piscifactorías y ojo que
la apuesta del gobierno no ha hecho nada
más que empezar claro que he llegado a
este punto estoy seguro de que la
pregunta que muchos os estaréis haciendo
es valvaler pero como se han lanzado a
semejante proyecto qué motivos tiene el
gobierno de singapur para haberse
lanzado a perseguir la apuesta 30 por 30
express por qué diantres han invertido
ya más de 200 millones de dólares en
esta apuesta pues amigos el argumento
principal que han puesto sobre la mesa
no es otro que el de la seguridad
alimentaria como encontramos al
principio de este vídeo singapur es casi
totalmente dependiente de las
importaciones para alimentar a su
población claro que sin embargo al mismo
tiempo como también os contábamos este
es el país del mundo
mayor seguridad alimentaria la pregunta
es cómo es posible o una cosa o la otra
no os parece
[Música]
singapur importar los alimentos de una
cantidad enorme de lugares diferentes en
total en 2019 este país importó
alimentos de más de 170 países distintos
lógicamente es muy difícil que de
repente un gran número de 270 países
tuvieran problemas para suplir a
singapur de todo lo que necesita esta
especie de república urbana pero claro
entonces el argumento de la seguridad
alimentaria pierde peso muchos analistas
lo que dicen es que en realidad el
gobierno persigue de momento tres
objetivos por un lado impulsar la
investigación tecnológica y crear nuevos
empleos por otro incrementar la calidad
y no en sí misma la cantidad en
particular en lo relacionado con los
productos frescos y en tercer lugar
mejorar la imagen del país reduciendo su
huella de carbono reducir las
importaciones alimentarias supondría
reducir el uso de transportes de cargas
y por tanto le facilitaría singapur
cumplir sus compromisos en cuanto a
emisiones de gases contaminantes
desde luego sobre el papel todo parece
muy bonito pero ahora bien hay algún
país donde singapur pueda mirar y decir
si es posible hacerlo y merece la pena
pues si lo cierto es que sí aunque a
decir verdad está un poquito lejos de
esta ciudad soberana concretamente en
europa hablamos por supuesto de los
países bajos un país que como ya os
contamos aquí en visual política ha
logrado convertirse en uno de los
mayores exportadores de alimentos
agrícolas de todo el mundo alimentos que
cultivan en avanzadas invernaderos
utilizando la última tecnología pero
queréis refrescar la memoria pues
atentos por carmen y largo plazo este
puede ser el resultado con el que sueña
el gobierno de singapur
[Música]
la era del led y el clima artificial
a ver desde fuera muchas de estas
explotaciones pueden parecer
invernaderos normales pero por dentro la
cosa cambia el ejemplo en grande ese es
simple y llanamente impresionante desde
el año 2000 han logrado que muchas
granjas tradicionales se reconviertan en
granjas de alta tecnología multiplicando
la producción y reduciendo los recursos
empleados a la mitad y todo sin
prácticamente utilizar pesticidas
químicos en el proceso incluso en las
granjas de aves de corral más modernas
el uso de antibióticos ha reducido un
60%
y gracias a este nuevo modelo de
agricultura los países bajos han logrado
convertirse medido en dólares en el
segundo mayor exportador de alimentos de
todo el mundo sólo por detrás de los
mismísimos estados unidos cuyo
territorios 270 veces más grande además
en el país existe todo un cluster de más
de 20 universidades centradas en la
investigación agrícola
o sea resumiendo los neerlandeses
producen mucho más en menos espacio de
forma más sostenible y encima les ha
permitido convertirse en una potencia de
exportación agrícola quien lo hubiese
dicho
[Música]
claro que he llegado hasta aquí y quizás
el único elemento controvertido de toda
esta historia tiene que ver con el coste
y digo controvertido no porque esté mal
sino porque no nos engañemos es algo que
suele generar revuelo social montar una
tecnocracia requiere invertir mucho
muchísimo dinero por ejemplo una
explotación no sé de unos 10.000 metros
cuadrados puede implicar una inversión
de varias decenas de millones de dólares
lo que evidentemente pues no está al
alcance de cualquiera precisamente por
eso este tipo de explotaciones suelen
ser promovidas por medianas y grandes
empresas y dependen mucho de cómo
funcionen los canales de financiación de
tal forma que cuanto más desarrollados
estén los mercados financieros y menos
se dependa de la financiación bancaria
más inclusivo será este modelo es decir
ya no hablamos de la bucólica y bilic y
campestre stampa de las granjas de toda
la vida sino de auténticas fábricas de
producción alimentaria que pueden
terminar revolucionando todo el sector
primario de momento en el caso de
singapur por ejemplo los costes son
ligeramente más altos que las
importaciones de hecho con los datos que
se manejan los precios de los vegetales
producidos en estas granjas hitec son un
5% más altos que el de aquellos
importados desde países como malasia
indonesia o tailandia quiere decir esto
que no son competitivas pues amigos todo
lo contrario
[Música]
la diferencia como veis es muy reducida
y el coste de las explotaciones supra
innovadoras tiene que ver con la escala
y con la experiencia y el desarrollo
tecnológico es decir que si la actividad
está empezando y sus costes hoy por hoy
no son disparatados su margen de mejora
es gigantesco using our brains of war
team atrás tuve otros expulsados quality
labs suter minute to win it
así que quién sabe podrá singapur
terminar replicando el modelo de los
países bajos en el corazón de asia
logrará uno de los países más ricos de
la tierra convertirse en un importante
actor alimentario incluso no sé quizás
esta pueda ser la forma de evitar
noticias como esta el 10 por ciento de
los singapurenses tienen problemas para
acceder a alimentos suficientes seguros
y nutritivos en fin amigos sólo el
tiempo nos dará la respuesta correcta
pero de momento podemos abrir debate en
los comentarios qué pensáis de todos
estos nuevos modelos de explotación
agrícola os imagináis a las nuevas
estrellas de silicon valley shenzhen o
singapur plantando tomates zanahorias y
lechugas déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y ahora así este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvides darle
al botón de like i suscribirte abisal
polític si es que aún no lo has hecho
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]